when the Ottoman Empire sided with the
central powers and declared war on Leon
tante it put its very existence under
threat about four seconds after
receiving the declaration of war the
British French and Russians were already
discussing how to divide the Ottoman
territory in the end there were several
agreements the Anton powers came to the
1915 Constantinople agreement gave
Russia
well Constantinople and also Eastern
Anatolia and the Treaty of London signed
in the same year gave Italy this land to
the south yet the most important
agreement because it was the only one
that actually came close to being
implemented was the sykes-picot
agreement of 1916 now during the war the
ottomans were beset on all sides there
were of course the British in the French
fighting them across the Mediterranean
and Mesopotamia there were also the
Russians to the north the Greeks to the
West and in the south they faced the
Arab revolt and caused the creation of a
Jewish state it won't surprise you that
not everyone could get what they wanted
from the collapse of the Ottomans and so
Britain came up with a cunning plan to
keep everyone on board
they lied in early 1916 Britain offered
the sharif of mecca has seen bin ali an
empire of his own if he assisted the on
tante against the ottomans he would be
given all of this land to be known as
the kingdom of arabia which would be
free of european interference which of
course he was happy to agree to and so
began the Arab revolt yet whilst the
same was fighting this revolt the
British and French were negotiating what
would actually be done with the land
these negotiations saw Sir Mark Sykes on
the British side and George picot on the
French one determining who would get
what France had previously spent a lot
of money in these lands and so was
expecting a return for its investments
now Britain did tell the French that
they had offered these lands to the
Arabs but France refused to relinquish
its claims though saying it is unfair
that Britain would receive lands in
Arabia was France but not in the end
after many months of negotiations Sykes
and picot came to an agreement which was
inventive ly named the sykes-picot
agreement and it divided up the Ottoman
lands as such Hussein would get his
kingdom of Arabia but it would be much
smaller than the one promised he also
wouldn't be told about this change until
after the war because otherwise he might
stop fighting and that wouldn't do
Britain would gain a brand new colony
lower Mesopotamia centered on Basra and
would gain a puppet state here in
northern Arabia centered in Kirkuk the
French would gain a directly ruled
colony here in a puppet state centred on
Mosul
France had pushed hard to gain Mosul
because of that sweet sweet oil and
Britain granted it solely on the
condition that France also take all of
this territory too why well because
Britain had agreed to Russia gaining
eastern Anatolia and given that the two
were rivals in
Asia Britain didn't want to share a
border with them it was also agreed that
Palestine would become an
internationally run Protectorate so
after the Ottomans were defeated how
much of this Agreement was actually
implemented well not much when the
Russian Empire dropped out of the war
and fell to communist revolution their
needs were no longer important and so
Britain could push for more land to the
north furthermore just prior to the
British troops entering Jerusalem London
issued the Balfour Declaration this was
Britain's form of support for the
creation of a Jewish nation which would
remain under sole British control until
it was ready to be independent now the
reason why Britain could unilaterally
renege on its agreements with France was
that it was British imperial troops not
French ones which conquered these areas
in the end Britain gained all of this
landed the numerous colonies and
protectorates whereas France gained
Syria and Lebanon as you may have
guessed King Hussein was a tad upset
about being betrayed like this and for a
time he ruled over the kingdom of Hejaz
that was until it was conquered by the
British back Sultan of aged Abdul Aziz
evens out whose lands would soon after
become the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
in the end only the British really got
what they wanted in the long-term
consequences of the agreement are
immeasurably important the states of
Iraq Syria Lebanon Israel Kuwait Jordan
and Saudi Arabia although their borders
to this Agreement the modern Middle East
was born I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with extra
thanks to these patrons you can see on
screen for their continued support and
an extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologists as ARCA
Flash Danny Maloney party-boy coke
coolin Castleman Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Gustav Swan David Silverman
Winston hegwood Christian checky Maggie
packs Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Ike spinning
three plates are on the white and
Michael Reynolds